it shows all about helping you make your
business updates that it's about how can
you get at that point where you might
have been doing this for a while I'm
losing motivation and you're not you've
seen the rope anymore you're not feeling
the momentum anymore this show is all
issues now I also want to welcome a new
producers to the show daniela is with us
today and hopefully we're going to have
a lot of fun so what I want tacos today
is telling your story and how important
it is to help you stand out from
everybody else okay let's get input tell
your story this is one of the biggest
things that can really help grow your
business a lot of entrepreneurs be
overlooked you have to remember the
people want to buy some people they
don't want to buy some company and yet
nobody really does a great job I'm
telling their story so few punch
brothers do a great job of telling her
story saying why they started part is
important to them because if you want me
to find from you did I have to feel
connected to you if I feel connected to
you I feel like I can trust you like it
I feel like your passion about what
you're doing I feel like you're going to
do good by me this isn't a buy your
product I'm gonna fire service when it
starts with telling your story look at
over wings beer / Winfrey's people love
her she's a multi-billionaire people
love Oprah even if she tells her story
so while she does deeply connected to
everybody she's interviewing and she's
vulnerable rakesh singh what she thinks
she's saying what she killed and when
she wants to cry she cries right and so
that personal story telling and me going
on that journey with her and you was not
going on that journey with her makes it
so easy to connect with her and then buy
stuff right for book club right if she
recommend the book it immediately say
stop so I wanted to know what your story
is because it's book
help you stand out against your
competition especially be going up
against big guy because big company is
such a terrible job of telling their
personal stories there's such a
corporate entity and we hate sorry from
the big guys right you look at any big
compliment look at their their Twitter
angle they're being slammed all the time
don't be like financing the big guys but
you need to do your job center so let me
tell you quickly about my story however
the helping entrepreneurs when I sold my
business I have a virus my software
company built it up and sold little 22
years old and I didn't want to do next
kind of shy you know happiest all their
business but also sad that this thing
was now gone I didn't know what to do
next with my life and I was invited by
the ymca to come speak to their young
group of entrepreneurs and if I think
brings opportunity get back why not and
it's been all this time they're firing
my slide I wanted all of my dollars on
them provide tons of value for them and
these motives are audience I post my
audience it was a free advantage booked
a huge room full of chairs all the
credit to go as the day comes and my
heart beating fast my first time really
doing speaking on my hands all sweaty
again in the elevator and take a deep
breath before going into the room like
this is a all that work here we go and
in my heart stopped for a couple seconds
because after all that work only three
people showed up Wow three people show
that with the free advantage of you
people shut up but the show must go on
the put it on and I'm really helpful to
people it was awesome and and then I
said you know what I love this so much i
have to keep doing it even if even my
don't know how I'm gonna make money it I
gotta find a way to keep doing it and
that was 12 years ago kind of kept going
on helping our economic action I want to
know what drives you what you're so
excited about what your story is making
connect to you so they don't bond
whatever process servers you I want me
to the call I have hot on the line five
Marines from and how can I
thanks for taking a call I am actually
from Chicago but I'm in the process of
the next year here moving back out to
Portland Oregon to start taking care of
some family but I run a business called
the DIY pro and my passion is is
bridging the gap with homeowners
construction and contractors and part of
the businesses is actually with working
with homeowners who want to do some of
the work themselves and actually
teaching them how to do it so if you
wanted to tell your bathroom floor and
weren't really sure you may be winter
one of those home depot classes on
Saturday morning but still realize that
maybe there's a little bit too much for
me I spend all spent time teaching and
then when you got the hang of it I just
let you go you go on them in their home
or this is done online yeah this is one
on what okay we lost time so you know I
didn't really get to Selena clean what
park board is all about we reduced a
connection there but Todd we still on
the line you know I love this business
model I'm trying to figure out you know
highly scale this up if you're going in
in visiting people in their houses and
you're helping them Tyler laughing or
whatever it is yeah how do you scale
that up so that that one hour they come
and show them is going to be worthwhile
honey build that name brand but I think
it's a huge huge need for right the
reason why Home Depot took off was
because people wanted to learn how to do
things themselves that was the whole
point of wing the homeschool feminist
argument was they wanted to have a place
where people could feel likely to do
this work themselves not have to go and
always hire an expensive contractor
plumber or it isn't coming and so you're
taking another level you know you might
be saying hey Joe some people workshops
they're not good enough we need
something to come into our location and
help me and teach me and show me the
rules of how to make it work but again
my concerning their time you scale this
up you know how do you re scale up to
the point where you're being paid for
your time
I'm in the travel time and you have been
a lot of time with breaking news been
the whole city there's chill me how to
tile bathroom in jail an hour two hours
and then I don't need your help anymore
how does that you know how do you get
picture down enough so you can scale
this you under stop you know this might
be a good one man show but ideally want
to build a business to the point where
you can get out of this right you are
not having to do everything you're going
in and beautiful and nearly as an
entrepreneur you can set up be the CEO
and contractors working under you go
haven't do anything so that's my biggest
question time you make that big lot of
work again especially moving into moving
to a new city in Oregon I need exact
work as well you might look like in my
husband said online matsu you mentioned
that's where you want to go but you
might look at an online models logically
how hot back on the line they're hot yes
and thanks sorry I and another the best
spot here right now with a client but
yes alright so I work with customers to
kind of help them to whether they want
to do it themselves i also do commercial
they would call it a third-party owner
representative and just to help make
sure contractors are doing the right job
so so that's kind of what I do but the
struggle is always in the residential
market is finding the best marketing
stress now are you actually going in and
meeting people in their houses and enjoy
service for that I'm you didn't believe
her an hour that we charlie yeah I had
you know on a larger project I will do
as a whole bid as if it was every other
contractor and then I put in an hourly
you know what my what I think it's going
to take me as far as time and I just
built by an hour and the more they do
the work the less i am on the job at
night and that they credit back to them
scale is dealing this you can afford the
higher people under shoe so let me not
go into each well one of the things I've
been looking at when I started to do my
business plan I was recognizing that the
Democrat
x4 my employ are going to be middle-aged
tradesmen experienced and you know the
bigger picture for me was to prove the
model and maybe consider franchising it
but in the in the meantime what I'm
doing it I think he's all hot against
five you are driving in and out of some
crazies reception zone so I was trying
to get on a landline to give us a call
back in welcome back to the oven
Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs I want to see you have
mass text your company and today we're
talking about telling your stories and
how important it is to make a connection
with your audience so that they will try
to like you and want to buy some the
first step in that is having a picture
okay have a picture of yourself a
smiling picture of yourself in that
profession outfit or something that
relates to your work because people want
to see the person are buying from it's
really simple okay you don't have to
start up or anything crazy a simple
picture of you smiling okay the first
picture that I had at me don't work
being professional you have to worry
about you know you're looking if you
think you're ugly or whatever to worry
about it doesn't have to be super high
quality right but the first picture I
used was one that a friend of mine cook
that was on a cruise ship having dinner
and you know I had my suit on a big
smile on and I use that for five years
of my business and it was it was helpful
people saw it too saw the smile and the
connection with me so I want to see a
picture on your website and need to be
on your marketing materials your
business cards if people will look at
pictures that's how you want to start
okay storytelling is crucial people
connect with people and it starts with
your picture on all your marketing
materials okay I want to get to the call
I have Clara on the line Claire where
are you from how can I help hi I'm so
then Cooper hey probably okay I know ya
figger to keep it you know keeps me on
the whole land loving it what's
nothing I hope well let's just let me
give you a little bit CliffsNotes
version I just so you understand my
backstory so I'm 26 now female I am
incredibly driven I'm very savvy I'm
smart and I'm not delusional I'm
actually stating facts that I believe
are pretty true but I'm also you
describe I heard in one of your other
shows that wannabe entrepreneur
currently that's working in a you know
corporate job or whatever hating my life
but the difference between night is I
absolutely know for sure that I'm not
going to be staying in that realm there
is no way and I don't want anybody
telling me what I can and can't eat my
lunch you know that's just not really my
so my jam it's absolutely out of the
question I'll stay in that but the other
thing which is putting major breaks on
that on my progress I guess is that I've
incredibly over analytical and as they
say you know fools are always going for
it and the intelligent people are full
of doubt I mean somewhat somewhat relate
to that but at the same time not so much
because I'm surrounded by so many
successful people who are risk takers
and such and my parents have this
mentality of you know European
immigrants work hard but don't take
risks to undermine your security right
on and that has brakes on my you know
natural enterprising personality and so
it's causing me to over analyze myself
out of every single idea that I have to
the point of nonsense and I know that i
am aware of this so my question to you
is I've been getting a lot of
sensationalized advice I would say from
a lot from successful people which is
basically that some of them will tell me
put your job just literally go today
quit your job right now that's what they
tell me okay and while that sounds
fantastic and I absolutely have the
balls to do that at the same time I'm
having a hard time merging out with
reality because I'm wondering and I
shooting myself in the foot by you know
having bills pile up and then what
happens if you have no if you don't have
something concrete to go on because I
don't yet so it you know and
I wouldn't say quit your job okay don't
quit your job yet okay the new sport
because momentum and sustain momentum is
really important because if you put your
job and you know you have three months
of money to live off of you know what
happens when your honor that money is
two months with people backing another
job where it's better to spend time
every day to build your business and
grow it because it may take six months
to get something off the ground and so
it allows you to spend more time and you
have some income coming in what I would
say is if you're looking for a job we
didn't have a job isn't just money the
reason to have a job is to teach you
something and so what I would look at is
whatever business you want to get in go
find the company that has you know 10
employees that is doing what you want to
do this is the competent you want to be
in a couple years and go work for them
because they're going to teach you how
to run that kind of business they're
going to teach you you're going to make
money you're going to make mistakes
you're going to make contact it's like
going to university for what you want to
do but being paid to do it so instead of
being stuck in some dead-end job but you
don't life and you're not being treated
well and you know you'll be told when I
eat your lunch and all that now you're
doing something that you're learning
from you're making contacts when you
start your company you are going to hit
the ground running at the same time I
still start on the side and those things
so much about it happens to be perfect
because whatever plan you come up with
it's going to change that's an inch of a
business find you have the perfect
business plan and as soon as you start
running your business people change so
just start start something start small
start talking to customers don't invest
a lot of money into the put some time
and you see what feels right until you
find what you're really passionate about
then start on you can try couple
different things and see where your
heart is leaving and see where your
energy is focusing you so that would be
my advice is if you're going to do a job
find one that is in dentistry you want
to be into so you can learn and then
start now start on the side and spend 20
30 60 minutes a day trying to build your
business
I like that yeah so it does that's much
more realistic than some of the because
with your advice is also real like a
little bit more applicable to today's
world where some people that I know have
started their businesses you know back
in the day where it was totally
different as far as the landscape they
were it was a little bit more informal
but this makes a lot more sense you know
quitting your job and and going all in
the server business can absolutely work
it can work it just dramatically
increases the risk of failure yeah yeah
yeah I don't make it work and you got to
go back and get a job and and you might
think well if I I just a little bit more
time to make that work we didn't run out
of money I could have really made that
work and you you know maybe live the
rest of your life in regret saying man I
Richard really have a chance to make you
about a shot okay that's good I'm so
glad you're telling me this because it's
in line with what I was exactly what I
was thinking but from the standpoint of
other entrepreneurs they see this as me
being hesitant and I said well I think
I'm being a little bit smart because I'm
trying to not be sound really cool on a
paper but then you know having to have
nothing to show for it but so it's
always listen to what feels right for
you that's going to be the best answer
but at the same time make sure that you
are still taking steps so when i text
art a part time you actually have to go
and do something part time right you're
spending 20 30 60 minutes a day on your
business and you might be jumping from
what ideas and next to pay that happens
in startups but you have to actually do
something every day to get this thing
off the ground
yes I understand I can't be stagnant in
all talk absolutely thanks for calling
also good luck thank you so much guys
and as for everybody listening if you're
in that same position you warm at the
entrepreneur you know one day you want
to start a company but but you know you
haven't done it yet you'll have to go
and quit your job just make sure the job
then you're at you're learning something
from you're gaining connections you're
gaining experience so that when you do
go and start and you eventually your job
you have this wealth of knowledge to
build off of and then start our size do
something part time every day to help
you grow your business hello and welcome
back to the Evan Carmichael show I
believe in entrepreneurs and today we're
talking about how to share your story in
a way people can connect with you
because people buy some people and not
some company so now I want to get into
specifics I want to talk about specific
things that you should be sharing with I
go to be a bell page of your website
here are some of the things I'm going to
see looking your about page right now
it's probably pretty boring most
companies websites on the about page is
super boring I want to feel connected to
you so you got to think about some of
the things are going to stand out right
you should read your belt page and feel
something if you don't feel anything
besides you know this is boring then you
have to keep going you gotta you gotta
tweak it up you got to add some changes
here are some of the things I want to
think about okay think about what we one
word is so this is a whole other
discussion but you know I believe every
on sperm has one word that defines them
I want you to write down on that page
what it is what it means to you tell me
why you started this business okay there
should be some passion me Highness this
isn't just to make a lot of money all
right you're starting this business
because you want to help people why tell
me the story behind it tell me about
what your fears were when you start what
were you scared to do tell me how you
transition from your job into creating
this business tell me how you found your
first customer tell me who the founders
are it is it just used you have partners
tell me how you made your first big
break you know who is that first big
deal that you close
said wow you know this is this is
impressive for us tell me about
milestones of reach their awards you've
won and the media you've been in it tell
me tell me the goals that you have for
yourself the vision for you where you
want to taste your business I again it
can't be in a boring way so you look at
most about pages and you see our mission
is to be the world's leading provider of
telecommunication services that's boring
I have to mean something actually
something that you are proud that you
created this and when you read it you
start to get emotional because if you
get emotional with it then your
customers are right I want to feel your
passion because I don't want to hire
just some dogs and come cut my grass or
come and do my tiling or provide me
telecom services I want to work with
somebody what feels was really
passionate what they do this is your
advantage as an entrepreneur you started
this business for a reason for a
passionate reason to help people and if
you're not sharing that story then
you're going to lose clients because you
would rather work with people who love
what they do and that shines through so
tell me those big i also want to share
some personal stuff not deeply personal
stuff but a little bit are you married
you have kids where'd you go to school
what are your favorite hobbies you know
what are your favorite food or music for
TV shows or movies or sports what if
some of your fears and I'm afraid of
pipes a little trial Blue Jays I love
salsa dancing and detain and you
thinking wife and this is really this
isn't really relevant to my business
what it is it is because I get so many
people who come up to me at advanced or
email me they feel like they know me
because I share so much information on
my show and my youtube videos and in my
newsletter and when people feel like
they know you then they're much more
loyal to you they're much more likely to
buy your stock they're much more likely
to tell their friends about you so you
have to make it personal you have to
share these things okay make it exciting
make it passionate make it emotional you
get back going you're going to convert a
lot more sales now I want to get to the
column I have
Laurie on the line Laurie where are you
from and how can I help hi I'm in New
York City so I'm listening to everything
you're saying I have so many different
kinds of about need pages all over the
place and Jerry and I keep reinventing
myself um I actually took a course I
went back to school cuz i have writing a
lot of writing experience but i wanted
to get more internet skills marketing so
i went back to NYU and got a certificate
in the digital marketing and so I've
done a lot of different things I wrote a
book about how to start a subscription
box company and I've gotten a lot of
clients from my book um so but a lot of
those people who are just starting
really didn't have much money so I've
had like some consulting but not enough
so now I'm want to expand it into
general marketing business on writing
and you know getting bigger clients so
you want to figure out how you can be a
marketing itself yeah I got a website my
brand strategist calm and that's where
i'm trying to do it from um i have like
another website blog my TV calm and i
write it at TV i do celebrity interviews
i'm going to america's got talent and
doing the red carpet but I do i do a lot
of promotion for other people for
writing articles and you know but I
don't make money at that stuff right
well why not why not i I don't know I
mean I haven't i've looked and looking
for a job i try to you know get a job at
late i mean if i could get a job at like
people or you know ritee or something
like that that would be great but I was
in LA I moved back to New York I mean
I'm just trying to do something where I
can make money i know a lot about a lot
of different things um I know content
marketing and you know brand strategy in
digital marketing and mobile marketing
and
but mostly I tell people I'm a writer
but I also can up their rank google
ranking and I um I know SEO won so those
so you're kind of listen to your kind of
all over the place right there's ratio
and yeah i'm at marketing and branding
and and so you either create an agency
will you do this and your your one stop
marketing shop for you specialize in one
thing and become the best in the world
of that and people know you as hey you
know you want to get this then you gotta
call lori from new york city's if you
love getting publicity for people and
you do a great job as on and and you do
that you know day in day out no problem
you're getting results for me well you
could charge for that right there are PR
agents and that's what their role is to
get publicity for their clients hmm i
think it's more figuring out what are
these things view love doing the most
and then focusing on a specific target
market i got all those things what do
you what do you most packed in the bed
yeah I'm most passionate I mean I do get
a lot of publicity for people i started
the TV site because blog my TV because I
got tired of people telling me to throw
out my TV I'd go to see like Gary
Vaynerchuk speak and you know he'd be
like your television you're wasting your
time and I was like the one person who
likes my TV better than my computer so
you talking about like so you've had
some successes how were your fashion
event okay so getting publicity for
people so why not create a business
around that um I'm usually the one on
the other side of it I I don't know how
to start like I have done to bliss be
four people in the subscription box
arena and I'm mostly the one who's
writing about other key I don't know how
to get the claims i guess that's that's
the thing i don't know how to get paid
clients I know how to write um um write
bringing but I don't know how to like
ask for money or get people to pay me
more
right well first you have to create a
package right so what do i get if i so
need you in the PR business right here
is a monthly retainer so i'm paying you
a thousand bucks two thousand bucks five
thousand bucks a month whatever it is
you to go out and promote me so what do
i get for my five thousand dollars a
month what are you going to do for me
right so you can write articles you can
try to line up interviews you can
interview me on your own media so your
own websites and all that stuff but it's
putting together a package for me that I
can say yeah I'm nothing coming
celebrity I'm a musician I want to get
out there I'm a speaker and I'm you know
you look at this very speaker speaker
houses you can look at any of those guys
today I want to help promote you to get
more business if you got to give me a
package and you can find all the stuff
that you've been doing and say you know
we're going to help you with your SEO
and we're going to help you giving the
media and we're going to write our own
content about you you can be on our own
media properties and I'm going to work
to get you another media or no other
interviews I'm going to get you TV show
Neil whatever it is that you are going
to work on whatever you're good at
whatever you love doing and put that
into a package and say this is going to
cost you two thousand a month five
thousand month whatever it is it has to
be clear it makes that clear then it's
easier for me to sign up does that make
sense yes that makes sense said is I
mean a package of what people tell me
when I was doing the subscription box
you know consulting and people ask what
i charge and I end up doing like
everything writing and fixing my water
fate and everything it's got a great
clear when I visit your site we've got
to go go to the commercial break but if
you want to email me when you create
your package i'll be happy to check it
out and give you some feedback okay Lori
okay I appreciate it thank all those
welcome back to the Evan Carmichael show
I believe in entrepreneurs and this show
is all about making your success today
we're talking about telling your stories
about making a personal connection to
people if people feel like you are
action about what you're doing and they
understand why you got into this
business they're much more likely to buy
from you to what I do business with you
to one
four people on cheese now one of the
biggest things that I get back from
people when I started saying this is you
know Evan this isn't about me it's not
about myself I don't have this huge ego
I don't need to be in the spotlight is
about the customer is about providing
that was great service it's about
offering a great product to them and
it's true and it's not about an eagle
place for you right it's not about
building up and saying how great of a
person you are okay because people can
see through that is this big eagle
maniac and that's what you're just
sharing all over the place where look at
me look out where I am people can see
through that and you're not going to
connect with people the key is the
approach if you're humble if you're
honest if you're passionate then that's
the story that you want to share I want
to know why you're so excited about this
business what it means to you because if
I can feel what it means to you what is
so important to you that I'm much more
likely to pick you over everybody else
so here is the store when I was first
starting up I have a software company
and I was in University and you know 19
years old and growing up I just wanted
to be a banker look at my high school
yearbook is I want to be a bank girl huh
10 years are going to be a BP at a bank
and I got University and I met up with
two friends and they had started this
business in software and they needed
help you know they had great product but
they didn't they didn't know how to sell
it and I don't know anything about
science I know anything about computers
and I joined to be the COO and I was out
there development partnerships and
getting media and trying to you know
build this thing up and it was really
hard you know I was making three hundred
dollars a month on this three hundred
dollars a month i was eating beans every
day for lunch because i couldn't afford
anything else if we made any kind of
sale we want to celebrate we'll go to
McDonald's and get french fries that was
our celebration so when you talk about
how hard it is to write a business I
said
so I was there and telling your story
like this is an easy way for people to
connect with you migrate came when you
know it's graduating University and I
had opportunities to work at McKinsey
Consulting and merrill lynch and only a
couple years ago that would have been my
ideal job you know wow I can't hear it
is i want to be a banker here's my
chance II need 100k starting salary
traveling around the world they flew me
to New York and put me up on the wall
before story ahs to go through the
process and something inside of me felt
like you know I want to give I want to
give my business a try I want to you
know it didn't make any sense 80 to 100
thousand dollars starting salaries and
that or do my business where i was
making 300 bucks a month how does that
make any sense it did you know my friend
saddle was crazy think they were the
keys to those jobs that i was going that
I got opportunities for it and you know
what I didn't want to live my life in
regret I thought you know what those
jobs will always be there could take a
year off instead of traveling with some
of my friends were I'll take a year and
put it into my business because I don't
want to look back when I'm 70 look back
on my life and and regret that you know
I didn't take that shot and so I stuck
with my business and the turning point
came when I realized you know I was
trying to come with everything myself
and I realize you know i'm at the first
guy to try to sell software before and I
looked at Microsoft and looked at how
they how they close their deals how they
went from 0 to 1 million you know how
they make it extra million dollars now
is not interesting for me but do it or
one I want to do that that's what I want
to do and this isn't partnerships and
after struggling and after telling my
partner that I quit and crying and
feeling so low on myself for feeling
like I should be able to get way better
results that I'm getting you know I'm a
I was a smart person I'm working hard
i'm not slacking off my trying to rip
people off and i'm i'm not seeing
results what do I have to do to get
results
and by looking on Microsoft and model in
their success expose my first
partnership feel the distribution
agreement for 13 and a half thousand
dollars now that may not seem like a lot
of money to you but to me that was that
was huge I make it even two bucks a
month use a 13 a half thousand dollar
deal that was awesome i was on top of
the world i went out and celebrated with
more than just french fries I no one did
it again and again and again and landed
big deals with johnson Johnson and NASA
and got us into media and within a
couple years had sold the business we
got so much attention that we got
acquired and my two business partners
moved to California with the deal and I
stayed here and then started my new
business so that's how I got started you
know those are some of my fears I was
worried that I wasn't going to work out
and I trusted in my gut that I didn't
want to live with regret for the rest of
my life and it's funny that now some of
my friends come back and they took those
banking jobs and if the oven can we meet
up for coffee and we'd go out and
they're like you know Evan I hate my job
I'm thinking of starting my own business
when I don't have a lifestyle and and of
course whatever to help them but it
makes me feel like wow I'm so glad I did
that decision instead instead of kicking
that job so you have to tell your story
you know when i get up in front of a
room of entrepreneurs and I shared that
story it makes him connect to me better
than much is this you know dude
successful entrepreneur and you know
what I think doesn't apply to you if you
just start enough I was there yeah I was
struggling I was making the three
hundred dollars a month I know what it's
like it wasn't that long ago a sauce and
I cried a nice told my partner I quit
and I was ready to go and get a job but
something kept me in it and so all the
advice that I share with you guys that's
where it comes from and so I want you to
learn to share your story it makes it
way more forces took me you know a
decade to really learn the power of
telling your story I wouldn't be so much
more further
if I started earlier so I want that for
you tell your story tell me why you
started this make it important make it
passionate make me connect to you and
I'm going to buy from you I'm going to
tell my friends about you I'm going to
be a loyal customer I'm going to love
and keep going back that wraps up
another show I want to thank my
producers daniela awesome for show Josh
as usual you rock I'm back in two weeks
in the meantime keep believing stay
strong and I will see you soon